le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
concerne le rsi un sujet sur lequel nous
avons ré ça récemment échangé par écrit
nous savons tous que les affiliés du rsi
souffrent de ces dysfonctionnements
allant jusqu'à mettre en danger le
principe fondamental de la solidarité
nationale
ces femmes et ces hommes se battent pour
survivre ils sont pourtant les acteurs
essentiels du maillage économique et des
créateurs d'emplois
aujourd'hui ils sont en grande détresse
le moral et la confiance de ces
indépendants sont au plus bas le régime
social des indépendants n'a plus rien de
social qu'ils les asphyxient les
mouvements de contestation prospère
d'ailleurs la décision du tgi de nice du
11 décembre 2014 démontre la fragilité
du régime
son avenir r il est remis en question
alors qu'un régime spécifique est
indispensable en outre-mer la situation
est plus dégradée encore une fois le
plafond annuel de la sécurité sociale
atteint les indépendants sont assommés
par le doublement des cotisations il
faut absolument réfléchir à plus de
progressivité dans les cotisations pour
ne pas tuer l'oeuf la tuer dans l'oeuf
la réussite excusez moi je pense aussi
aux artisans et commerçants retraités
certains pourraient ne bénéficier que
d'une pension d'une centaine d'euros
après une vie de travail j'ai rencontré
un homme il ya quelques jours qu'ils ne
touchent que 80 euros de pension rendez
vous compte
cette détresse est une réalité
quotidienne et elle s'ajoute aux appels
à cotisation a justifié souvent évoqué
c'est une véritable situation d'urgence
vous avez fait quelques propositions
dans le cadre du plfss pour 2016
cependant quelles autres mesures
efficaces
allez-vous proposer aux artisans et
commerçants qui sont dans la tente et
dans quel délai sur ce sujet il faut
aller vite
je vous remercie monsieur robert la
parole à madame la secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce
artisanat de la consommation et
l'économie sociale et solidaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry robert monsieur le député fait
votre question fait état de plusieurs
points mais je voudrais revenir sur deux
points en particulier et notamment
concernant le régime des du rsi des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
les travailleurs indépendants l'aï
bénéficient d'un régime particulier
ils sont exonérés et je veux leur
rappeler dans cet hémicycle pendant deux
ans ils sont exonérés de cotisations
puis leurs revenus professionnels
inférieurs ou égaux au plafond annuel de
la sécurité sociale que l'on appelle
passe et de 38000 40 euros et il
bénéficie d'un abattement de 50%
ensuite les cotisations elle suit bien
évidemment le niveau des revenus
concernant ce que vous évoquez et le
mouvement en fait de désaffiliation la
sécurité sociale je veux le le rappeler
est fondé sur la solidarité nationale et
sur l'universalité
concrètement toute personne quels que
soient ses ressources où son état de
santé qu'on cotise en fonction de sa
capacité et bénéficient de prestations
sociales c'est je crois notre
responsabilité collective d'élus de
décideurs de créer les conditions d'un
régime adapté aux spécificités des chefs
d'entreprise c'est bien monsieur le
député la feuille de route de notre
gouvernement et nous le prouvons
concrètement et nous continuerons pour
que ce régime soit plus lisible et plus
simple dans l'esprit d'équité qui anime
ce gouvernement